[Musik]
die rose profitieren sind unternehmen
sind verständliche politiker sind
verständliche klartext angestellter alle
borussen stehen sind von dem system und
nachteile jeder bürger steht derzeit
jede private wohnbau etwas ausbauen
gemeinde statt
[Musik]
und so entschied sich adam kommt rooney
aus dem bau kartell auszusteigen
die preisabsprachen nicht mehr zu
akzeptieren
die machenschaften aufzudecken und
auszumisten
[Musik]
adam quadri früher selber bauunternehmer
heute lebt er von hilfsarbeiten und
zuwendung
er lieferte den behörden die
entscheidenden hinweise über die bündner
bau kartelle jahrzehnte lang hielten
sich die unterengadiner bauunternehmer
gegenseitig aufträge zu und sprachen die
preise ab 2012 nahm das ein jähes ende
[Musik]
ab und zu hilft adam kidron ii bei
august koller aus der bauer aus dem
toggenburg lebt schon lange im
unterengadin er ist einer der wenigen
die öffentlich zu adam toni stehen
dieser führte für august koller einen
seine letzten aufträge als
bauunternehmer aus den kontakt stellte
ein bekannter her kennen gelernt und
fährt ist er fertig sind verglichen
also 5 prozent günstig sie 10 uhr fährte
gegenüber 4 2-erfolg der charts perfekt
adam toni hatte so offeriert wie er es
für richtig hielt als er 2013 für august
kollabierte war er längst aus dem system
der baum absprachen ausgestiegen
in dieser luft dort und ich will dass
sie ein hofer betroffen weil ich mal
sagen im prinzip anschluss die oder filz
die überbauten vorteil ist dass sich
ordnen das einmal luft
[Musik]
ramos das heimatdorf von adam quattro
nie 1200 meter über meer rund 500
einwohner
eine die die verhältnisse im
unterengadin bestens kennt ist die
unternehmens und kultur beraterin oder
famos
sie wurde hier geboren auch wenn sie
längst im unterland liebt ist sie
beruflich und privat eng mit der heimat
verbunden
adam quattro nie kennt sie von
kindsbeinen an
aber wir wachsen
den aufruf man kennt sich man weiß wer
mehr wert ist und von dem her kenne ich
ihn eigentlich schon sehr viele er
diesen zählen zu unseren mensch umfragen
ich kenne ihn als sehr belesene belesene
person er diesen eingeprügelt
das habe ich schon immer geschätzt habe
johannes fleer menschen anders finde ich
die gesellschaft funktioniert wie wieder
durchschnittlich erwischen eigener kerli
am dorfleben nimmt adam quattro nie
längst nicht mehr teil
er lebt völlig isoliert viele wandten
sich von ihm ab nachdem er das bei
kartell auffliegen ließ er entschloss
sich bei den absprachen nicht mehr
mitzumachen als sein erstes kind geboren
wurde
[Musik]
seither ziehen können das muss er doch
recht ich seh und hat ihr könnt ihr das
machen wenn wir selber nicht bin
deswegen das geht nicht
die vorstellig jetzt lernt das kind
velofahrer zum beispiel gab dass fehler
und denkmal das kind mit dem velo fahrer
dort um den muss man vor stellige zahl
der wähler kauft mit dem gelddrucken und
eines tages kunz kind das schlimmste und
ist frei papa warum es betrüger
adam port rooney wohnt allein in seinem
haus seine frau hat ihn vor zweieinhalb
jahren verlassen und die drei
gemeinsamen töchter mitgenommen
seither kämpft er darum den kontakt mit
seinen kindern nicht zu verlieren
es gab eine zeit in der alles anders war
als adam kidron ii 2002 heiratete nahm
das halbe dorf am fest teil
die familie kommt rooney in dritter
generation eingewandert aus italien
gehörte dazu
das glück des jungen paares schien
perfekt gleich neben dem elternhaus
baute adam kidron sein eigenes
großzügiges haus schon bald kündigte
sich nachwuchs an
heute hält nur noch seine schwester
jaqueline zu ihm
sie sind die beiden jüngsten von fünf
geschwistern adam kidron i stieg nach
der maurerlehre ins baugeschäft der
eltern ein
seine schwester arbeitete ebenfalls dort
am abend besuchte er das technikum in
chur und machte noch einen abschluss als
polier und bauleiter die baufirma
quattro nie lief gut doch das hatte
seinen preis
adam quattro niveau anfang 20 als sein
vater ihn in den 1990 er jahren zum
ersten mal an einer versammlung der
bauunternehmer mit namen mehrheit ja g2
geht das was nicht richtig ist aber
mehrmals über- leben mit und das ist
tatsächlich so werden wir da nicht
mitmacht
ein hitler wenig chance zum überleben
kies oder zu überteuerten preisen oder
transport geben / wegen nicht oder sie
sagen aus genau dem zeitpunkt an
das ist einfach boykottiert und da hat
man wenig chancen gut da nicht außer sie
eingeredet baumeister aber es ist man
hier so klar sie was deutlich läuft wann
ich denn nicht weit worden bin und was
ist schon schrecklich was da läuft und
der papa schnee derjenigen hätte das
nichtwähler und radam auch sie schon
nicht wollte sie das ist sich als andere
networks zum überleben hat man das hat
mitgemacht
die bauunternehmer trafen sich in einer
firma oder einem restaurant
organisiert vom baumeisterverband anfang
jahr teilten sie projekte untereinander
auf wenn ein bau dann ausgeschrieben
wurde kamen sie wieder zusammen und
legten erstens den preis fest
und bestimmten zweitens das unternehmen
welches den auftrag ausführen sollte
vermeintliche konkurrenz auf herten
mussten höher sein als der sowieso schon
überhöhte preis des unternehmens das für
den auftrag auserkoren worden war
die absprachen wurden bis ins letzte
detail schriftlich festgehalten
um wie viel viel hat man dann prise
festkleid von 20 bis 40% 50 auf bis zu
100 prozent
aufgrund der dokumente die adam quattro
nie gesammelt hatte leitete die
wettbewerbskommission 2012 eine
untersuchung ein
frank stüssi begleitete die
untersuchungen jahrelang rad an quattro
nie hat damals tierbabys auf dem tisch
hat klärt was im engadin im unterengadin
abläuft und er ist rösler sexy hat eine
untersuchung der hand gesetzes das was
uns zeigt dass sich das bewahrheitet hat
das ist sie also glaubwürdigkeit und
lüftern auf dem stimmt das was er seit
aus das zusammen sind dokument die hand
ich das hat sich bewahrheitet
eine der umfangreichsten untersuchungen
von insgesamt zehn wahn engadin 1 die
weko sprach sanktionen in der höhe von
7,5 millionen franken aus den größten
teil der busse von rund 5 millionen
franken müssen bachelor die not und
volker conradt zahlen hinter den firmen
standen einflussreiche männer duri
bezzola langjähriger verwaltungsrat
der bachelor den mut ag ehemaliger
nationalrat
er will sich nicht vor der kamera äußern
roland konrad langjähriger
verwaltungsratspräsident der vfa konrad
bis 2014 saß er als grossrat in bündner
kantonsparlament
auch er gibt kein interview foto konrad
und bachelor die note gehören heute zur
tester gruppe gegen die verfügung der
weko haben sie beschwerde eingereicht
die bau absprachen sei nicht so lange
und nicht in dem ausmaß durchgeführt
worden
wie die weko geltend mache zudem seien
absprachen lange gang und gäbe gewesen
nicht nur im baugewerbe bis ins vierte
quartal ist die stelle überhaupt gehört
und mehr hat nun zusammen ins
meerrettich setze ich für thommy ten
profi hat und nun will man bis erlaubt
oder trixi heißt das nicht dass man sich
noch ein gesperrtes folter mit dem fan
entschuldigen
ob sachsen ins gespräch preisabsprachen
sind uns wohl einzige der schweiz
[Musik]
oder famos stammt aus einer wohlhabenden
familie als die firmen bachelor und
demut mitte der 1990 er jahre
fusionierten saß sie wenige jahre als
finanz geberin im verwaltungsrat der
neuen unternehmung von den absprachen
habe sie nichts mitbekommen aber sie
beschäftigen sie kurz jedes dorf hat es
unternehmer cover mit dem bau sie nur
klassische aus und dann hätten die hat
ganzen branche vom bau immer herzlich
natürlich glaubt verdauen gemein sind
car zum wohle von klein sind die
arbeiter gerecht verteilte er durfte auf
die einzelnen mieter zieht und mit dem
volumen von wachstum auf umbau wachstum
wo ist und auch verteidiger von der
firma durch fusionen durch käufe durch
natürlich auch konkurrenz für user sind
dir der der private betreiber immer mehr
unter druck
und ich glaube denen sich einfach unsere
protektionistische situation unser hält
sich dezent geschlossen zum ruhrgebiet
muss verteilen aber auch wieder kurze
zeit und das ist natürlich danach als
musiker auch lino geld verdienen und
immer mehr geld verdienen
im unterengadin kamen die bauunternehmer
in scuol auch nach 2004 noch zusammen
als das kartellgesetz verschärft worden
war und gebiets abreden und
preisabsprachen sanktioniert worden
[Musik]
oktober bergbahnen
das gebäude
und etwa sogar 70
für verteidiger altersheim
die später an
[Musik]
schon zu beginn der 2000er jahre redete
adam port rooney über die bau absprachen
er sprach grossräte an angestellte des
tiefbauamts und jung dominique parolini
ein weiterer einflussreicher mann der
heutige bündner regierungsrat war von
2000 bis 2014
gemeindepräsident von spuren ins leere
laufen jahre lang profi krise dass da
irgendetwas nicht stimmt und damit
europa erzählt arbeitet bis absprache
finden start up unternehmer tätern dort
los und ich sage inklusive hätte mirko
ich hatte auch nicht richtig zur closed
und anita mich unbedingt wert auf das
thema in monaco ist etwas auswählen
tigers engagiert hat will ja will er tat
auch vergangenheit und erhält auch opfer
produziert so zeigen also mit seiner
firma auch nicht immer gradlinig sie
tatsächlich adam kidron ii geriet immer
mehr in geschäftliche schwierigkeiten
weil er nicht mehr bei den
preisabsprachen mitmachen wollte mit dem
bau eines eigenen betonwerks versuchte
er sich unabhängig zu machen
[Musik]
es funktionierte nicht
die anderen bauunternehmer sagen quattro
nis sorgten dafür dass sie nicht
beliefert wurden sind gegen höchst
silvia steger thema poker tmn man jetzt
vernichtet
das hauptproblem ist dass zum teil der
deloitte hängt mit der kundenkontakt
mini kundenkontakt oft nur dann dem die
zahl 1000 zahlungsbefehl wir sind
einfach nicht zu dem gertrud steigen das
sind einfach gestand sie gewaltige uns
einfach mit ihnen doch sogar mit st
obwohl das man der bestätigung hängt das
man dass man meint sie denn jetzt
gemeint und konnten betriebe zum teil
hanne betriebe rico mit victory und
betriebsamt design aber ein guter freund
ist vom andere sprache
[Musik]
die einflussreichen männer des unter
engadin
keiner nimmt vor der kamera stellung
sie wandten sich gegen adam kidron ii
das angst trotz mancher will natürlich
natürlich das was man macht und ihr die
kartellabsprache dass das das hätte
natürlich wlan einfach wieder nach und
hinter eine weile her warum wo es
tägliche branche nicht dass ich nicht
genutzt
es ist ganz klar dass eine stütze so
einer muss man möglichst schnell das ist
dass der ruf wird mit dem mit dem seil
oder damit damit machen wie bisher immer
wieder dass sich ein trend zu stetigen
verändert gewesen
oder man hätte sie nicht wählen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
und dass die märkte hinein sinclair
niveau aber dir die russen baufehler
führt das hin zur königin dahinter
politische macht die handy kennt arbeit
die es in große arbeitgeber gehen der
marktposition im wirtschaftsraum in
green und wer direkt der hätte macht
denn nicht nur interessante politische
ämter sind entsetzt werk und bezüger
das ist natürlich so dass ist nicht der
dass der tasten stark macht oder und bau
ist starke lobby und bau ist ein
wichtiger bestandteil der existenz wo
ganz ganz viele familien hinter dem tor
aber
2006 stieg adam quattro nie nach einem
wüsten streit bei einer sitzung ganz aus
dem bau kartell aus drei jahre später
nahm er nochmals einen anlauf wieder
ging er zum gemeindepräsidenten und zum
tiefbauamt des kantons graubünden in
chur
[Musik]
im tiefbauamt ics denkt anhand von dem
was man da besprochen kein heil ich will
nichts für kalkar dass da etwas könnte
passieren
nach zwei buch ist also wieder vorbei
von dominique parolini im film will sich
nichts zu adam patron ii und dem bau
kartell äußern
vor zwei jahren sagte er rückblickend
wenn wir jetzt etwas für dimensionen
asamoah wärme sensibel das ist ganz klar
da wird man den schrittmacher 2009 nach
dem treffen mit adam kidron informierte
er sogar die bauunternehmer problem dass
er jetzt das offiziell weiß nicht dass
es gibt sondern dass er jetzt weiß ich
noch in einem medaillon unfähiger hinter
stunde es kann jemand der stunde sie
hans grüßt bereits informiert
keine stellen am morgen kommt rooney und
seine dokumente ernst die behörden
gingen den absprachen nicht nach adam
court rooney wurde immer mehr isoliert
[Musik]
im schnitt können zaubern abhält sie
nicht gleichzeitig informiert ich kenne
privat bewohnten aufs geld wartet uns
geld nicht wild aber gleichzeitig ist er
immer nur mit mit dem natur wagennummer
gefahr und vermittelt wird oder aber
könig haut und das sind auch
familienväter sie und ich bin persönlich
vorgang sei nach dem sinn lohn
ich kannte kennt ihren crews der bruch
das salz in der suppe und dann nicht
über nacht und den friedhof um
unbezahlte ich mir worten oder und so
ist ich kenne jetzt einfacher ganz
konkret habe ich weiß es geht nur
angriffe oder und so macht man sich auch
nicht glaubwürdig erscheinen erst dann
zeigen wie gut ich kaufe zahle ich
glaube dort hätte wenige kraft kampf um
das sie gestaltet dass er das lieber
kannten das essen im takt
[Musik]
- in natürlich groß akzeptiert schritt
wie es mit gemacht
janssen vertritt sie haben alle fehler
gemacht und der situation unter dem
druck entstanden ist macht man fehler
zudem erstaune der knall kam 2018 durch
eine artikel serie im online-magazin
republik wurde die geschichte des
baukonzerns einer breiteren
öffentlichkeit bekannt ein paar tage
lang wurde adam quattro nie für seinen
mut gefeiert doch es ging nicht lange
und seine integrität wurde infrage
gestellt dass die glaubwürdigkeit von
whistleblowern angezweifelt wird
geschieht häufig deshalb setzt sich der
ehemalige bundesgerichtspräsident giusep
nay heute für adam kidron ii 1
solche geschichten kennt der
pensionierte bundesrichter aus seinem
berufsleben corti mal stand so dass
öffentlichkeit wichtige persönlichkeit
der öffentlichkeit lied wo betitelt
sehen die der wirtschaft vaudoise
scherzte werden und liebt den rallye
lüth aus vertraten volles wird aber kein
und 0 grad sauna irgendwo mistelbacher
das bild auch zerstörer tastend ludwig r
und entstand tatsache war noch kaum
beachtet wird er ist wie sie am cut
rooneys glaubwürdigkeit wurde unter
anderem deshalb in zweifel gezogen weil
er geschäftlich und privat konkurs
anmelden
nach zahlungsausfällen und betreibungen
nicht mit dem finger auf ihn zeigen aber
sie trauen sich nicht so direkt aber im
markt dass da irgendwas ist dass sie
gern wild visser oder den köpfen gemacht
bei der abwicklung der konkurse lief
mutmaßlich einiges falsch
erst langsam kommen ungereimtheiten ans
licht
bisher hieß es einfach adamkus rooney
habe selber leute über den tisch gezogen
das sind es gibt es geht keinerlei
indizien für service industrie für
aufgaben vor dem uno bisher auf kompakte
nie sierte kennen sind glüht wo selbach
daher quattro nie in die situation
braucht wenn ihm noch der vorwurf machen
einen grundkurs schilderte bis ins die
lytro in konkurs streber hemd zugewandte
säge hammer aber
adamkus ronis ehemaliger buchhalter
reichte strafanzeige gegen ihn ein und
erhob schwere vorwürfe da der sache wo
im dichten wert und der mich immer
hellhörig macht und dann habe ich eine
patrone akuter und da haben wir das
immer sehr plausibel und können erklären
und hat so dass sie die konstruktion
schnell und zwischen den markt gegen
westerlo bei die abwicklung des
privatkonkurses laut adam quattro nie
von den behörden verschleppt wurde
konnte er diese angelegenheit bis heute
nicht abschließen
er zahlt einen hohen preis er hat nicht
nur sein geschäft verloren sondern auch
seine ehre
alles hängt mit dem zweimal
ich bin unter dem sozialen abstieg gilt
auch adam konnte rooneys ehe hinter
seinem rücken plante seine frau ihn zu
verlassen und die drei gemeinsamen
töchter mitzunehmen
heute weiß adam kidron ii dass sie sich
an die behörden wandte weil sie sich
angeblich bedroht fühlte von ihm und
sagte ihr mann hegel suizidgedanken
damit setzte sie eine kaskade von
dramatischen ereignissen in gang
am 15 juni 2017 reinigte adam port
rooney sein mayens es
er war auf dem rückweg nach ramos als er
hier verhaftet wurde von einer grüner
gier sondereinheit der polizei
da bin ich doch eh radfahrer und ein
bußtag standard und johanna kalt und auf
einer höhe mit den hofer lüth und für
polizisten vermuten mit mit wasser
schreien 3 1 martin schlager standen
schlecht
die polizei brachte adam kommt rooney
auf den polizeiposten in the wall wo
eine leibesvisitation durchgeführt wurde
später wurde er in die psychiatrische
klinik nach chur gefahren
hinter dem rücken mit handschellen
[Musik]
die herren glaubt and rock und weiß gott
was wenn sie bis komisch klagt während
der untersuchung hängt im weg seid mein
gott das ist nicht zum glaube wenn ich
texte haben mit mit auf platz die lakers
geschlagen worden
also so dass geht's nicht gemeint ich
bin da immer noch immer falsche vielen
motto warum warum das ganze wochenende
über monster adam kidron ii in der
psychiatrischen klinik ausharren
nach vier tagen wurde er entlassen
[Musik]
die psychiater der klinik waldhaus
sagten ihm er müsse sich bei der
hausärztin im nachbardorf zur
nachbetreuung melden
iris solcher wurde von den ärzten vorab
informiert ecuador hat mir diese
geschichte erzählt von dieser
ingewahrsamnahme durch die polizei und
dem psychiatrischen dienst und hier ist
also erstmal der unterkiefer
runtergefallen was da alles kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen ist wirklich da
versorgt worden und mit gewalt also auch
diese wesentliche umstände der
ingewahrsamnahme mit mit handschellen
und also auch die psychiater die am
extrem gestaunt offenbar war das den
diesen titel hier und da mal mit mit
fürsorgerischen unterbringen
konfrontiert aber so also das haben wir
glaube ich seit das erleben sie selten
mit augenbinden und han china das
geschäft
während adam quattro nie in der klinik
war zog seine frau mit den drei töchtern
aus das war von langer hand geplant aus
dem psychiatrie akten geht hervor dass
sich die psychiater keinen reim darauf
machen konnten weshalb bei madame bruni
eine fürsorgerische unterbringung kurz
eu angeordnet wurde
die grundlagen der finden konnten von
hier aus nicht sicher verifiziert werden
also bald tasten der beobachtungszeit
konnte man da keine anhaltspunkte
von seiten der kest konnten ebenfalls
keine hinweise auf das laufende
verfahren oder sachdienliche
hintergründe gegeben werden es wurde von
dieser seite schon im umfeld der
einweisung mitgeteilt dass die ehefrau
während des klinikaufenthalts zusammen
mit den kindern aus der gemeinsamen
wohnung ausziehen werde
und wir wurden die betenden patienten
über das wochenende in der klinik zu
behalten und ihres zürcher schrieb dem
zuständigen regionalgericht sofort dass
die enge bindung zwischen vater und
töchtern während der trennung der eltern
besonders geschützt werden müsse aus
medizinischer sicht empfehle ich deshalb
baldmöglichst an der regelmäßigen
gegebenenfalls begleiteten kontakt
zwischen vater und kindern zu
ermöglichen und zu organisieren wie es
umgesetzt wurden 1 0
das ist da ist quasi gar nicht darauf
reagiert worden
was für ein unglaublich einen
gewichtigen anteil an dieser situation
hat ein weiterer einflussreicher mann
orlando zeck präsident des regional
gerichts unterengadin
er führte bis ende 2018 verschiedene
verfahren gegen adam petroni vor allem
konkurs er schutz und
scheidungsverfahren angelo schweizer ist
adam kidron ihs anwalt für die konkurs
betreibungs- und familienrechtlichen
verfahren unserer familie
transportvehikel und vatertag sind der
ehemalige geschäftspartner von macronix
im rahmen von babbel sind dunkel um
vater zeigt jeweils am quattro nie als
unternehmer zur tank sie vor dem
kampfrichter wahl uns regional präsidium
vor namhaften rhythmus im bild v kartell
unterstützt wurde nahmen noch am ohr
leihen conrad
[Musik]
für mini der schweiz als rechtsstaat ist
es eigentlich undenkbar auch sie dass
der adam quattro nie eine solche richter
gegenüber strom im vorfeld programme
schiedsverfahren und im rahmen von
messverfahren hätte orlando vehement ein
bild von ihrer selbst und rick fertig
adam chronik schaffe die ganze
verfahrens leitung sei auf schikane und
zermürbung ausgelegt adam caron ist
alles und jedes kämpfen ja in der
schweiz wurde gegenstand von verfahren
doch sehr beschränkt ist unterhalt
rinder belang zur wiesn honig kann ich
nun hier in derartigen akten umfang sie
in einem schreiben an angelo schweizer
weist orlando zeigt jegliche vorwürfe
von befangenheit zurück vor der kamera
nimmt er nicht stellung
dass sich adam kidron ii nach seinem
privat und geschäftskunden überhaupt
anwälte leisten kann hatte den lesern
des online-magazins republik zu
verdanken
unter ihnen war natalie wildermuth der
kurzentschlossen ein crowdfunding für
ihn startete an einer feier im november
2008 zehn erzählt er den spendern wie er
von ihrer großzügigkeit förmlich
überrollt wurde also zeit ich will
innerhalb der 107
und beim crowdfunding ist so weil man
innerhalb von derzeit weniger gesammelt
wird alles wieder zurück gewann also
acht diese frau kann nur zusammen
gewertet werde es kann alles
interessiert so klose darum ist das
ganze risiko xiii und 48 tore sind schon
50 frauen zusammen sich hotels und auf
samstag sind über 130 franken sammeln
und kampagne ziele erreichen und am ende
sind es über 40 millionen sind für eine
harmonisierung kräftig heute würde ich
es wichtig dass man die schweiz
so wird in zukunft das schicksal von
adam toni bewegt 4
seit wir sehr schätzen
mit deren unterstützung gerechnet und
angekauft
das kann ja auch nicht erwartet das
hilft mir sehr sehr viel damit
metergenau danken herzlich danke für
alles gesorgt beim crowdfunding dafür
dass die einnahmen im sinn der spender
verwendet werden
in erster linie werden am cut rooneys
anwälte mit dem geld bezahlt
joseph deiss aufgabe ist nicht immer
einfach weil das gesammelte geld nach
den regeln der crowdfunding plattform
rechtlich gesehen nathanael wildermuth
gehört kann das konkurs und
betreibungsamt nicht darauf zugreifen
für ihren turnaround das stimmig und
verbünde ist das heimrecht die artikel
serie der republik und die verfügung der
wettbewerbskommission erschütterten im
frühsommer 2018 den bündner wahlkampf
der geschäftsführer des bündner
baumeisterverband etwa zog schon vorher
seine kandidatur zurück dominique
parolini schaffte seine wiederwahl nur
knapp
verschiedene untersuchungen wurden
massiert die erste parlamentarische
untersuchungskommission des kantons
graubünden wurde einberufen
zudem setzte die bündner
kantonsregierung professoren und
außerordentliche staatsanwälte zur
aufklärung ein
[Musik]
adam kommt rooney versucht mit einer
seiner töchter zu telefonieren
doch sie will oder darf nicht
da sagte ich habe ja
das telefongespräche nur kurz oder gar
nicht stattfinden kommt häufig vor
[Musik]
der kontakt mit den kindern läuft sehr
schlecht vom regionalgericht wurde das
entscheiden in dem urteil das sie darf
dreimal in der woche nach ostern und die
kinder uneingeschränkt könnt mit mir
kontakt haben und das ist festleiter
realität ist ganz ein andere weder adam
port louis frau noch ihre anwältin noch
die anwältin der kinder nehmen vor der
kamera stellung im er schutz verfahren
würden sich die auswirkungen des
whistleblowers unmittelbar zeigen sagen
adam petroni und sein anwalt die familie
dort trifft muss ihn im innersten und
dort mit kamera kaputt macht der
regional richter roland zegg habe stets
partei für die gegenseite genommen sagt
angelo schweizer er zeigt zum beispiel
das baby ständen und in richtung bevor
er ins befragungen im umfeld von der
macht der heißt mikroskops woche
behauptet unter massiven einfluss vor
dem tor stand nur sprachlich völlig
falsch
üblicherweise würden kind befragungen an
einem neutralen ort geführt
in diesem fall beispielsweise am
regionalgericht sicher nicht bei einem
elternteil
damit nicht genug im dezember 2017
lehnte orlando zeigt ein gesuch um
unbegleitete besuche der kinder über die
feiertage ab heute ist anzunehmen dass
er auf dieser basis versuchte adam
quattro nie kurz vor weihnachten erneut
in der psychiatrie zu versorgung hand
dazu bieten sollte er ist sicher am 22
das dann erreichte sehr geehrte frau dr
aufgrund einer vom gutachter
gefürchteten möglichen negativen
veränderungen von herrn adam quattrone
psychischen zustand nach kenntnisnahme
des heutigen gerichtsentscheides werden
sie als hausärztin psychotherapeutin von
herrn adam quattro nie dringend
aufgefordert umgehend und jetzt kommts
fett gedruckt die nötigen
vorbereitungsmaßnahmen zu treffen
beziehungsweise diese zu veranlassen
im nachhinein drängt sich so das gefühl
aus dass man so darauf gehofft hat dass
ich da sagen bevor irgendwas passiert
und es ist weihnachten und dann bin ich
auch nicht da ich auch weihnachten
keinen dienst und bevor irgendwas
passiert bevor sich dann der herr
quattro nicht was antut versorgen wir
irgendwie war es so dass ich ihn
irgendwie ja auch wieder in die
psychiatrie einweisen so nach dem motto
dann habe ich alles getan was ich was
ich tun konnte so so für meine eigene
sicherheit dass ich noch besser schlafen
kann und dass das gefühl hatte ich das
da so wie sie darauf spekuliert wurde
das bild dass adam kidron ii eine
gefährliche person hielt orlando z
weiter aufrecht die ehe schutz
verhandlung ein jahr später im
gemeindehaus von sproll fand unter
massivem polizeischutz statt
[Musik]
im unterengadin stören sich viele daran
dass adam cottreau nie den weg an die
öffentlichkeit wählte den meisten gilt
er als nestbeschmutzer selbst leute die
ihm wohlgesinnt sind ziehen es vor zu
schweigen
nicht ohne grund ein ehemaliger kunde
von adam toni der sich vor der kamera
äußern wollte zog seine zusage zurück er
war bei einem gespräch mit dem tv team
in school beobachtet worden
daraufhin wurde er mit dem ruin seines
geschäfts bedroht falls er ein interview
geben würde
seither nicht machen mit ihnen das
interview zum spiel
ich fühle mich überhaupt nicht als
couragiert ich finde selbst versteckt
nicht dass ich da sitze und und minimale
größerer bin überhaupt nicht korrigiert
die dem sie aber also sind einige kennt
verlaufen sei das würde ich nicht machen
und das werden die strittigsten allem
das muss ich ja das stimmt mich traurig
dass das nicht möglich ist
das unterengadin und das bau karte hier
möchte man einen schlussstrich ziehen
und vorwärts schauen
die gemeindepräsidenten etwa drängen
darauf dass der kanton der vergabe von
bauaufträgen in der region wieder
normalisiert 2018 hatte er unternehmen
die an den bau absprachen beteiligt
waren keine arbeit mehr gegeben
man hängt jetzt die
untersuchungskommission aber laufen muss
sollten den staatsanwalt aufklären will
und alles macht man hängt eigentlich das
aber im hintergrund sind immer noch
viele annahmestellen und wo das
gegenteil machen
ich finde man sollte das thema dem tal
öffentlich diskutiert rolle von der
polizei trawler vom liegt der dollar
es ist also mehr über sie transparenz
schaffen die das wird vieles vieles
aufbrechen und denselben okay jetzt muss
man aus dem lerner ab was lernen wir aus
dem oder dem wir alles wieder klären der
zwischenbericht der parlamentarischen
untersuchungskommission von november
2009 10 sowie ein weiterer bericht
rehabilitieren adam scott rooney er sei
so unrechtmäßigen und
unverhältnismäßigen eingriffen in seine
persönliche freiheit gekommen
ebenfalls belegt ist dass die polizei
schon ein halbes jahr vorher plante adam
kidron ii zu verhaften und in die
psychiatrische klinik einzuweisen
um seine frau beim auszug mit den
kindern zu unterstützen
gegen regional richter orlando zweck
läuft mittlerweile ein strafverfahren
wegen amtsdelikte zahlreiche
untersuchungen auch die pug gehen weiter
für sie ist adam hat rooney weiterhin
wichtig als auskunftsperson aber auch
als lieferant von dokumenten
ich bin sehr froh dass das jetzt gemacht
wird das jahrelang für so etwas kämpft
ja auf der anderen seite kämpft um so
recht um ein kind mama sind sehr viele
baustellen und das macht so einem halber
kaputt dass jedes läuft der film ist
noch 90 minuten fährt über den link ein
ende
[Musik]
adam konnte rooney hofft auf
gerechtigkeit und vor allem dass er
seine töchter wieder ohne
einschränkungen sehen darf
beim ihres jahres dreimal des jahres
verlassen
da kann ja was bach
[Musik]